what do you think of that negotiation
forget terrorists but the global
negotiation like with with Vladimir
Putin the recent negotiation over
prisoners
The Exchange the Britney Gardner is
there a way to do that negotiation
successfully first of all I agree with
the idea that she was wrongfully
detained and that she hadn't and she
didn't deserve to be in jail and
that you discovered there should be no
second-class citizens ever and whether
you're an a WNBA player or you're just
some bonehead that walked into the wrong
situation your government should not
abandon you ever ever
now what they do
um in the meantime
there should have been a negotiation
they were desperate to make a deal at a
bad time they'd been offered far better
deals than prisoner swaps earlier and
turned them down
and then he gets turned up and thank God
for Brittany Greiner that um the public
got enough attention they kept pressure
on the administration they made a deal
now governments want to make those kind
of deals that's fine as long as it
because that was basically a political
negotiation you're putting five thousand
Taliban back on a Battlefield
that ain't negotiating with another
government you're putting five of them
back on a battlefield that ain't
negotiating with another government
that's directly contradicting this thing
that you claimed and those were all bad
deals now was the Brittany grinder thing
a bad deal I think it was great for her
if I was in the middle of it would have
been better
and she still would have come home yeah
there's some technical aspects of that
negotiation what do you think is the
value just the Ling on it of meeting in
person for the negotiation I think it's
a great idea